paris 2024 les jeux olympiques en france
c'est dans trois ans et en région
parisienne plus particulièrement
seine-saint-denis la construction de
nombreuses infrastructures sont prévues
une celle qui doit accueillir le village
des médias dans une partie du parc
départemental georges valbon plusieurs
associations déposent un recours devant
la cour administrative pour demander
l'annulation de la cession du terrain
par le conseil départemental de la
seine-saint-denis
la justice a rejeté le recours
rassemblement aujourd'hui à paris pour
en parler on retrouve tout de suite sur
place notre reporter mona modèle bonjour
à bonnat alors à ce que les militants
ont répondu présent à l'appel
jean
bonjour à venir écouter ils sont un peu
plus d'une cinquantaine à s'être
rassemblés ici devant l'hôtel de ville
apparaît à paris regarder juste derrière
moi ils tiennent tous d'un rameau
d'olivier
justement ils sont un peu plus d'une
cinquantaine malgré la pluie ils
protestent contre les jeux olympiques
qui vont se dérouler en 2024 dans le
département du 93 en seine saint denis
plusieurs associations ont répondu à
l'appel du groupe saccagé comme
l'indiqué son nom est bien il dénonce un
saccage écologique urbanistes politique
sociale est également plusieurs partis
politiques étaient également présents
dont l air france insoumise ou encore
europe ecologie les verts écoutait
notamment à ce propos et danielle
simonnet de la france 2
j'étais contre les jeux olympiques dès
le premier jour parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est plus la fête des sponsors que la
fête du sport
c'est toujours une facture énorme qui
sera payé par le peuple au détriment des
investissements nécessaires pour le
quotidien
et là on le voit bien les jeux
olympiques on nous les promet écologique
alors qu'en fait dans 93 on va bousiller
les jardins ouvriers
on va empiéter sur la courneuve on va
imposer un échangeur de l'autoroute a1
qui va aggraver la pollution des écoles
lieux autour
et tout ça pour finalement des profits
toujours pour les mêmes grosses
multinationales et la facture elle
augmente toujours plus je pense qu'il
faut que la mobilisation et je pense
qu'elle montera petit à petit monde qui
a d'autres priorités aujourd'hui que de
claquer l'argent public dans les jeux
olympiques
aujourd'hui il faut absolument qu'on
tire les enseignements aussi de la
pandémie pour se rendre compte qu'il
faut repenser notre mode de
développement dans un autre rapport au
vivant
alors de ce rassemblement qui est un
rassemblement statique et bien plusieurs
profils étaient à présent de retraités
des jeunes étudiants mais également des
enfants venus avec leurs parents et tout
cela malgré l'appui on a pu parler à
certains d'entre eux je vous propose de
les écouter
aujourd'hui c'est devenu une boîte à
fric
une boîte à sponsors et on est chouette
on fait l'esclavagisme entend courir des
gens en les faisant monter sur des
podiums où on leur fait miroiter des
choses sachant qu on a des jeux déjà qui
pourrait très bien fonctionner comme la
coupe d'europe comme la coupe du monde
nos sportifs sont déjà médaillés et là
on est dans l'immmédiat individualisme
total il faut arrêter cette aberration
à l'époque on se bat pour le climat on
se bat pour le musée de social le sport
n'est plus du tout ce qu'il était et il
y en a donné la nature et l'homme est
tout ce qu'il ya autour
ça a permis aussi d'être un prétexte
pour démolir des quartiers entiers pour
reconstruire derrière des éléments
qu'ils ont un rapport assez lointain
avec le sport des jeux olympiques
simplement pour faire fuir les habitants
les plus pauvres de la région parisienne
pour écouter le peuple
voilà c'est ça c'est écouter ce qui va
pas est pas resté en eau à faire comme
hbo comme vous ne semblez penser que le
peuple pense alors que c'est faux
plusieurs personnes à qui
nous plusieurs personnes à qui nous
avons pu parler on mentionnait également
la dangerosité danoise sait qui on est
et globale si elle était appliquée alors
des jeux olympiques en 2000 avant de
4,24 parlons quoi qu'il en soit et même
si la plupart savent que c'est eux jeux
olympiques ne seront peut-être pas
annulé ils continueront ce qu'ils
appellent la résistance justement pour
le climat l'écologie et les libertés
individuelles
d'ailleurs plusieurs rassemblements sont
prévus dans les semaines qui arrivent